je vous demande d'accueillir arnaud de
malaucène je suis dans un entrepôt d'une
belle pme 2000 personnes une ex-star top
qui cartonne je dois rencontrer à
jean-louis donc entrepôt logistique
je dois le rencontrer dans une petite
salle qui au milieu des rails vous savez
sur lesquelles circulent tous les colis
entre deux étapes d'empaquetage ya pas
mal de bruit je retrouve jean louis dans
une petite salle va très bien éclairé il
m'attend avec une dizaine de feuilles de
papier écrite à la main avec des
tableaux faire la règle au stylo et je
suis censé l'interrogé un peu sur quels
sont les problèmes de sa boîte quels
sont selon lui les noeuds de son
organisation et comment est ce qu'il
faudrait les adresser j'aime pas le
temps lui dire bonjour qui me dis tout
de suite on a un problème de qualité
du coup je suis bien embêté parce que la
qualité c'est pas mon domaine je suis
pas un expert technique jeu plutôt là
pour parler management rh la culture
d'entreprise tout ce qu'on appellerait
les enjeux humains du coup je lui posais
des questions savoir pourquoi selon lui
un problème de qualité
comment il a aperçu qu'est ce qu'ils
proposent comme solution est là jean
louis me raconte que ça fait six mois
six mois qui commande à la concurrence
sur ses propres deniers pour benchmark
et le service de son entreprise que tout
ce qui récupère comme data il l'inscrit
à sur ses feuilles en papier
ensuite il a acheté des bouquins
spécialisé sur amazon pour essayer de
voir comment on peut structurer un
service notamment un service qualité par
rapport à toutes les données qu'il a et
donc il me tend ses feuilles en disant
voilà mon service qualité donc j'ai un
service qualité entre les mains jeux pas
trop gourmands faire ce que je vais pas
être juge là dessus je demande pourquoi
me le donne à moi il me dit parce que
j'ai pas confiance dans mon manager
manager va me piquer l'idée je pense
vous avez déjà entendu un peu d histoire
similaire
il sait que je vois son patron le
lendemain c'est pour ça qu'ils me le
donne je le donnerai à son patron ça
aura un certain écho et en plus jean
louis veut s'investir sur le sujet et
donc il en aura l'occasion
la morale de cette histoire c'est que si
j'avais pas rencontré jean-louis et que
je l'avais pas remonté sa son patron
jean-louis il est invisible pour son
organisation
jean-louis il existe pas c'est violent
mais c'est vrai il fait son job très
bien fait plusieurs années qu'il est sur
cette plateforme logistique ça marche
bien je dis pas que c'est un numéro mais
je dis qu'il n'existe pas en tant que
talent en tant que personne capable
justement d'aller benchmarkée pendant
six mois sur ses propres finances pour
régler un problème de son entreprise
capable de prendre du recul sur ces
enjeux alors que franchement il n'a pas
vraiment le temps la journée pour
finalement essayé de trouver des
solutions pour sa boîte il est invisible
il est hors du radar il a 50 ans il a
pas son bac
ça fait déjà plusieurs années qu'il est
sur sa plate forme logistique sans avoir
à bouger
alors si l'entreprise n'est pas capable
de voir jean louis dans un monde où tout
change ou qu'il ya quand même beaucoup
d'entreprises qui se retrouvent avec des
business qui sont percutés où il faut
réagir assez rapidement pour pas se
faire discret pts et selon le mot à la
mode
si cette entreprise n'est pas capable de
voir jean louis alors elle a un problème
son entreprise à un problème mais
pourquoi sa boîte l'a pas vu quoi jean
louis aujourd'hui les ors du radar parce
qu'en fait comme beaucoup
d'organisations la notion de talent elle
est plutôt niché en eau de
l'organisation elle répond à un certain
nombre de critères qui sont plutôt un
cadre assez contraint il faut avoir fait
une certaines grandes écoles il faut
plutôt à voir certains réseaux plutôt le
bon costume si je caricature mais
finalement une fois qu'on remplit ces
critères on est en plus destiné à être
systématiquement dirigeants un talon
aujourd'hui en france il y est aiguillé
pour être dirigeant on a des gradués de
programmes des programmes de high
potential et cetera
l'enjeu c'est que tu sois le futur
dirigeant de la boîte que tu es le même
costume et les mêmes idées que ton
prédécesseur c'est pas le sujet donc on
a un talent qui est une case ultra figé
est dans un monde qui bouge et dans des
organisations qui se remettent en cause
de manière assez profonde avec cette
définition du talent jean louis les
ordres de l'équation
et jean-louis avec ses 10 feuilles de
papier qui m'a tendu il vient
questionner le talent il vient
finalement mettre le doigt sur le fait
que le talent tel qu'il est aujourd'hui
répond plus aux enjeux des organisations
parce que ces organisations bouge
elles doivent devenir plus agile selon
le terme à la mode mais la capacité à
réagir rapidement à s'adapter à une
obsolescence de compétences à s'adapter
à des collaborateurs qui vont rester
beaucoup moins longtemps dans
l'organisation à s'adapter à des
business models qui vont changer quand
accord vent se sépare de toutes ses
divisions qui possède les murs de ses
hôtels pour devenir une plateforme de
services vous imaginez un petit peu le
séisme en interne en terme
d'organisation
en france on a des organisations qui
sont pyramidale
michel serres parle du syndrome de la
tour eiffel tout est concentré vers le
haut ça descend ça remonte de temps en
temps et en tous cas tout est concentré
en eau sur les décisions
on dit qu'on va passer demain dans un
monde entreprises ultra libéré ultra
plates ou la crds ainsi tout ce qu'on
entend sans hiérarchie tout le monde
décide de tout ça va être formidable
moi j'y crois pas vraiment je pense
qu'on aura un entre deux qui s'appelle
la subsidiarité je vais prendre une
image pour parler de la subsidiarité
c'est le culbuto on va passer de la
pyramide au culbuto imaginer une
pyramide qui doit réagir assez
rapidement à aux enjeux qu'elle doit
relever c'est quand même assez compliqué
de bouger le culbuto c'est ce personnage
qui est monté sur un poids et quand je
tape le personnage va basculer dans un
sens ou dans l'autre mais
systématiquement il revient à sa
position centrale
ce culbuto c'est l'image du centre de
gravité de l'entreprise qui redescend
tout était en haut de la tour eiffel
aujourd'hui tout va redescendre ça veut
pas dire qu'il y aura plus rien la tête
ça veut juste dire que la capacité de
décision
elle devra se faire au plus proche du
terrain et si quelque chose remonte à la
tête c'est parce que la base n'a pas
réussi à la règle et c'est la
subsidiarité
quand on passe de la pyramide au culte
plutôt le changement il est quand même
assez violent pour certaines
organisations ou de pyramide est bien
bien l'encré et pour passer de cette
pyramide as culbuto il va falloir donner
une place à jean louis c'est une
histoire vraie jean-louis 1 c'est pas
quelque chose que j'ai inventé et pour
ça il va falloir se libérer du talent se
libérer
du fait que jean louis ne soit pas un
talent qui les cinquante ans qu'il est
pas son bac
on s'en fou qui n'est pas fait hec on
s'en fout terminé on se libère de tous
ces critères là on revient à la
définition brut du talent qui est la
capacité d'accomplir quelque chose à un
instant t
mais ça jean louis l'a prouvé qu'il est
capable de le faire donc si on oublie
ses critères jean louis est un talent et
le talent ça reste encore assez connoté
en france alors on va laisser le mot de
côté aussi on va basculer sur le
potentiel
jean louis c'est un potentiel on passe
d'un entonnoir ultra sélectifs du talent
qui vous mène à une case un peu uniforme
un espèce de tami hyper large où vous
allez avoir autant de cases que de
potentiels autant de cases que de jean
louis et ce à tous les niveaux de
l'organisation
et ça ça va complexifier un peu la vie
des entreprises parce que comment on
repère autant de potentiel hier c'était
plutôt facile
aujourd'hui il va falloir élargir un peu
le scope
il ya deux conditions pour sa une il
faut que le potentiel ils sont en
capacité de parler de lui de se montrer
et dont beaucoup de boîtes ya quand même
une autocensure qui est assez
gigantesque deuxième condition c'est
l'organisation doit permettre une fois
que ce talent a émergé connu de le faire
grandir de l'accompagner et de le faire
s'exprimer à plein là où il est parce
que l'entreprise va avoir besoin de lui
là où il est pas uniquement à la tête
donc il ya deux leviers pour ça l'école
et à une certaines modifications de
process dans l'entreprise
l'école tout d'abord je vous apprendrai
rien en vous disant qu'on a une école
qui est plutôt sur un modèle
d'inspiration napoléonienne donc plutôt
pyramidale est plutôt tour eiffel un
système qui est fait et qui a été
construit pour faire émerger des élites
même s'il ya des choses qui évoluent
aujourd'hui on est quand même toujours
sur ce schéma de un certain niveau ceux
qui sont au dessus et ceux qui sont en
dessous
l'école demain il va devoir basculer
dans un modèle où elle se concentre sur
le potentiel de chaque élève
on n'a pas un talon qui peut émerger on
a autant de potentiel que d'élèves
donc exit les deux trois filières qui
sont quasiment uniquement reconnu comme
pourvoyeuse de talents en france on
élargit le scope
exit le système à deux vitesses avec une
élite et le reste balance pas trop
finalement qui sont ils et pourquoi ils
sont là on va aller vers une
complémentarité des potentiels une
complémentarité entre celui qui a fait
hec
parce qu'on en aura toujours besoin je
dis pas qu'il faut tuer hec mais aussi
avec les jean louis complémentarité des
potentiels c'est un peu le modèle
scandinave particulièrement de modèle
danois les enseignants là-bas à l'école
ils sont formés une vingtaine de
pédagogie et je dis bien formés là où en
france c'est plutôt une sensibilisation
forme et avait un pédagogie pour
s'adapter aux élèves
l'enjeu c'est de faire émerger le
potentiel de chacun parce que chacun
aura un rôle dans la société demain et
au danemark un éboueur
il est fier de ce qui fait il est
reconnu pour ce qu'il fait dans la
société
je vais pas faire le parallèle avec la
france alors je vous laisse le faire
l'école de demain ce sera un peu une
école à la thierry marx thierry marx et
un chef étoilé que vous connaissez
sûrement tout ce qui lui a des écoles
dans les banlieues pour former à la
cuisine et il expliqué en disant qu' il
pouvait plus enseignée de la même
manière qu'aujourd'hui quand ils
arrivent devant ses élèves et qui leur
dit je vous apprends la recette de la
côte de boeuf il dit j'ai vingt
personnes ce qui sur ipad on dit
recettes de côte de boeuf
globalement ils n'ont pas besoin de moi
moi ce que je vais devoir leur apprendre
ce que je vais devoir leur apporter
c'est la capacité à faire émerger leur
propre signature leur propre potentiel
finalement leur individualité leur
valeur propre on est dans l'école de
demain on se concentre sur le potentiel
de l'élève
plutôt que d'essayer de le faire rentrer
dans une case une fois qu'on a
conscience de son potentiel qu'on est
capable de le porter un peu devant le
monde on arrive dans l'entreprise
hélas deux étapes la première qui le
recrutement le recrutement c'était
facile hier pour recruter un talon on
avait hec on avait une certaine
cooptation je caricature un peu mais
c'est quand même beaucoup comme ça dans
beaucoup de grands groupes avec qui on
travaille
et du coup on pouvait recruter le talent
de façon à ces normes et c'était
rationnelle ça rassure dans un grand
groupe
on sait qu'on a coché la case talons ça
veut pas dire que ces vecteurs de succès
mais en tout cas on est rassuré par un
process demain avec ce que je vous
décris ce tamis avec autant de cases que
de potentiels c'est à dire c'est un peu
le bordel quand même pour les boîtes on
va basculer du rationnel et
l'irrationnel et du coup ça complexifie
les process de recrutement et
rationnelle chez décathlon ils appellent
ça la ligne du bas du cv
on enlève les diplômes on enlève même
certaines expériences et on va se
concentrer sur les engagements sur
finalement ce que le gars ne dit pas
dans son cv sa capacité d'adaptation est
ce qu'il a envie
est-ce que c'est quelqu'un qui rayonne
est-ce que c'est quelqu'un qui travaille
collectifs etc etc
on va donner beaucoup plus de valeur à
tout ça mais ça c'est pas nouveau il ya
quand même déjà beaucoup de monde qui le
fait je pense que dans la salle il y en
a qui s'intéressent déjà à ça mais c'est
quand même un gap culturelle dans les
boîtes de noeux s'accrocher plus qu'à sa
deuxième irrationnelle c'est le feeling
demain le potentiel c'est quelqu'un qui
voudra bosser chez vous c'est un jean
louis qui va faire plus que son boulot
son potentiel il faut que vous le
séduise y est il va falloir le séduire
avec vos valeurs avec un adn très fort
avec une culture pas uniquement avec une
grille hyper normes et de compétences
pour voir s'y colle il va falloir
chercher le match parfait voir si
jean-louis en fait y colle aux valeurs à
l'adn de la boîte il a envie de
participer à cette aventure et pour
jean-louis voir si la boîte et leur
envie que jean-louis fasse partie de l'
aventure si on va avoir ce match parfait
donc en fait on bascule complètement
dans l'irrationnel et finalement on va
rentrer dans le règne de l'incertitude
c'est à dire que les entreprises vont
devoir apprendre à se planter
elle le faisait déjà avant mais on était
à 7 dans un process donc c'était quand
même un peu normes et il y avait
toujours un responsable demain dans le
recrutement elles vont devoir apprendre
à se planter et c'est pas grave le match
s'est jamais parfait y aura toujours des
erreurs
beaucoup d'entreprises aujourd'hui
recrutant groupe ils font venir
plusieurs candidats ils les challenge
sur une journée et derrière il ya un
autre pendant qui est la version
recruteurs aujourd'hui on a quand même
les rh certains managers qui sont
concernés nous dans notre boîte par
exemple c'est directement des
collaborateurs à qui vont rencontrer les
candidats et moi j'y crois beaucoup
on prend des profils de notre boîte qui
sont hyper différent et on va croiser
les intuitions pour essayer d'objectiver
le recrutement même si on sait que ce
sera pas toujours très juste on
acceptera de se planter
mais en tout cas si l'entreprise
n'accepte pas de se planter elle va
rester dans quelque chose de normes et
les potentiels comme jean-louis elle va
juste leur montrer une chose c'est qu'il
n'a pas sa place dans l'organisation
une fois que vous avez été recruté
vous êtes dans l'entreprise et là je
reviens à mon histoire de jean-louis
mais il m'a donné ces feuilles de papier
parce qu'il n'avait pas confiance dans
son manager la crise et la confiance il
ya quelques temps j'intervenais une
conférence est en creux je parlais de ce
sujet là et à la fin il ya un
commissaire à la réindustrialisation qui
est membre du ministère industrie qui me
pose une question qui dit c'est super
intéressant votre histoire de tami avec
autant de 15 que de potentiels du coup
le digital ça vachement nous servir avec
des algorithmes on va pouvoir repérer
tous ses potentiels
ok mais écoutez j'espère que vous vous
plaisez dans votre job mais en fait
c'est pas le sujet le sujet et le tamis
c'est le retour du management du
management pardon de proximité le tamis
ultra serré qui va permettre de faire
émerger le talent de lui faire confiance
et de faire que ce potentiel
il va apporter ce qui peut à la boîte là
où il est c'est le manager de proximité
pour ça il faut que le manager il change
de posture ça c'est pas nouveau vous le
savez tous aller plus vers de
l'accompagnement aller plus vers sa
capacité à faire grandir ce potentiel sa
capacité à sentir quand il doit mettre
en risque que le potentiel pour le faire
grandir
ça c'est déjà quelque chose qu'on entend
beaucoup dans les organisations
le truc qu'on entend pas bah c'est
pourquoi le manager il aurait intérêt à
faire ça on demande aux managers d'avoir
cette posture qui prend du temps mais il
est objective et est évalué sur la prod
et le pilotage de l'activité qui lui
prend déjà tout son temps donc le
manager proximité aujourd'hui n'a pas
intérêt à faire ce job est à changer de
posture
donc on doit changer le cadre du manager
ça doit devenir sa vraie mission et
c'est là où mon culbuto et prend tout
son sens et qui a démission du manager
qui sont chronophages qui doivent
redescendre au niveau du potentiel pour
libérer du temps aux managers et lui
permettre de se concentrer sur
l'accompagnement du potentiel ma
conclusion c'est pas qu'il faut
supprimer hec ça vous l'avez compris ma
conclusion c'est qu'il faut un peu lâché
prise lâcher les vieilles lunes
finalement c'est un peu le retour du
mérite et ça fait du bien en tout cas il
faut attendre ma conclusion c'est de
dire que finalement c'est un enjeu de
complémentarité danse culbuto là il y
aura besoin de la tête et des potentiels
qui sont à la tête et des potentiels qui
sont en bas demain on aura besoin d'une
complémentarité entre les deux pour que
l'organisme l'organisation pardon
puisse évoluer de manière suffisamment
rapide
cette complémentarité entre les
potentiels à tous les niveaux de
l'organisation
c'est la clé de la transformation et
beaucoup de tout bois tu passes à côté
et finalement quelque chose de
passionnant dans tout ça c'est que j'ai
pas parlé de digital j'ai uniquement
parler du vin et ça montre que l'enjeu
des transformations pour nous il est
profondément humain
bienvenue dans le monde des culbuto
[Applaudissements]